oh boy that's a really tough question
it's kind of like asking one of what are
the five countries you should know about
if you're not interested in geology or
geography or politics and the answer
varies depending what your actual
interests are or what what are the five
companies you should know but an answer
changes over time to back when I was
getting started lo these many decades
ago the answers would have been Fortran
COBOL basic Lisp and maybe APL and those
were very formative languages back then
and people learned a lot from those but
these days it might be more important
for you to know JavaScript even if the
only reason you know that is is that you
know whether or not to click the enable
JavaScript button in your browser but
javascript is a nice lightweight
object-oriented language and that's why
it can fit in a browser and do these
things such as run little programs that
that help you input your data and then
send it off to a web server somewhere
there are there are heavier weight
object-oriented languages and you know
the elephant of the room is sort of Java
you can't really make a list of modern
languages without talking about it Java
is sort of the the COBOL of the 21st
century I think it's a kind of
heavyweight verbose and everyone loves
to hate it they'll not even will admit
that but managers kind of like it
because it looks like you're getting a
lot done
you know if 100 lines of Java code
accomplish a task then it looks like
you've written a hundred lines even
though in a different language it might
only take five lines you know it's it's
like you know you can eat a one-pound
steak or you ki need a
100 pounds of shoe leather and you feel
a greater sense of accomplishment after
the shoe leather but you know maybe
there's some downsides but it also
because it is sort of considered an
industrial language and programmers are
sort of interchangeable parts managers
like it for that reason and for that
reason a lot of Java jobs have been
outsourced from the United States Oh
what are languages I think going in a
different direction
coming more from academia we have a
language like Haskell which we call a
functional programming language that
means function in a mathematical sense
not in the sense the other language that
other languages are dysfunctional but a
function mathematically has an input and
an output and it naps too you know with
a great deal of mathematical certainty
what those what those are so it Haskell
is one of those languages that
mathematician type minded people love
it's sort of a language for geniuses by
geniuses so you should probably know
about it if only to be able to say well
is this kind of like Haskell and if so
then you know you have to hire some
really part smart people to the program
in it Haskell is sort of a modern kind
of Lisp in that sense what else uh well
we can't we can't leave off modern
languages without talking about C the C
language that's just spelled with letter
C is actually about 40 years old
but people have tried to replace C with
other languages that are like it and
have by a large not succeeded because C
is a very minimalistic language and very
close to the metal as we say on a
machine and lets you get down and
and do very fine-grain stuff very
efficiently but it's a lot of hard work
and but once you've done that work you
can run it pretty much everywhere so
almost all the other languages that you
see Java Perl whatever actually if you
look down underneath they're actually
implemented in C or or in a closely
related language so that that continues
to be a very fundamental language if
only because everyone is trying to
reinvent it and not succeeding in doing
so and finally for a fifth language well
you'd probably want to pick one of the
scripting languages there's there's
several to choose from
there's Python there's Ruby but of
course I am a prejudiced in favor of
Perl because I think it has the the
liveliest community and because we have
intentionally been redesigning it lately
to leapfrog all the other languages for
the for the last number of years we've
been redesigning it to take out all the
warts that we've noticed over time and
we figured it was just our one chance to
break backward compatibility break the
things that need breaking keep all the
things that make pearl pearl keep it a
joy to use and with this redesign make
it a language that will be able to be
useful and enjoyable for decades and so
I'd recommend Perl but I'm known to be
prejudiced in the matter